[Musik]
perfekt die reinste Augenweide ich mit
meinem ganzen Leben noch nie so eine
Wunder wunderschöne Braut gesehen
einfach wunderschön finden Sie nicht
auch ja natürlich sicherlich Schatz wenn
ich nicht schon um deine Hand angehalten
hätte ich würde es jetzt tun ich müsste
es tun mein Herzblatt mein alles
ich bin hier jede vierte Mann ist zu
eitel eine Brille zu tragen und riskiert
damit jede Menge leicht vermeidbaren
Ärger
da warte ja Friedrich komm zu mir
Hause das muss nicht sein Brille Mayer
ihr sympathischer Optiker mit Herz und
Durchblick 6 mal in Bayern und
sicherlich auch in ihrer Stadt
ich würde dann gern zahlen bitte
Entschuldigung suchen sie mich
dann dort hinten oh Brille Maier ihr
sympathischer Optiker kommen Sie lieber
heute als morgen
entschuldigen Sie mich bitte im Moment
[Musik]
[Applaus]